now i am i look at this
and i find it a little bit awkward okay
i'll tell you why i find it awkward
let's think back to the normal
derivatives you're used to okay a normal
derivative from a normal function okay
something like this you know i don't
know
okay there's a normal function okay and
you differentiate it and what would you
get
no seriously what would you get
3x squared
minus 12x cubed
plus one constant okay good look at no
problems okay
now have a look at this with me you have
a derivative a rate of change okay
what's it in terms of
it's in terms of x it's in terms of the
input that makes sense
the original function was in terms of
input so your derivative already changes
also in terms of the input right
but what do you have down here
this is weird this looks a little bit
like what we get out of sort of like
implicit differentiation sometimes but
usually like those variables are mixed
this is unusual because i have a rate of
change not in terms of the input time
but in terms of the output h that's kind
of it's kind of weird i mean it's it's
still true we drew some conclusions from
it and it makes sense of what we observe
but it's a bit weird it's a little bit
weird okay so my question to you is can
we get this in terms of time
can you get in terms of time
now i'm gonna before i show it to you i
want you to have a think about it i want
you to try on your own theme
can you get an expression for d h on dt
that's not in terms of h that's in terms
of time could you work it out
i'll give you a few minutes to have a
think about it
i'll leave all that information on the
board
give it a go
let's give this a go remember i told you
you have to think about what you know
about this
and bring it to bear onto this okay and
that is hard it's conceptually hard okay
so let me walk you through a little bit
and hold your hand okay
we've been talking about derivatives
haven't we all these rates of change and
so on okay but derivatives are only
half of what you know about calculus
aren't they it's really half what's the
other half of calculus
it's integration isn't it now admittedly
this is this is making elite but stay
with me okay we know this
we know that
okay
so
what'd you got to tell you that you can
take that statement and turn it into
another statement through integration
now here's the reason why i'm going in
that direction okay
i want some relationship between
dh and dt right but i don't want it in
terms of h i want it back in terms of t
what's the theme that connects h
and v and t
and the answer is it's back up here it's
it's volume
volume connects the height and the
what i'm looking at uh and time right
so that's why i'm coming back to this
step right that's why i've gone here
it's not just arbitrary like let me just
pick an equation and see what i can do
with it i pick this one because if i can
express
time and volume together i can get to
height okay so watch right what
statement could you make out of this
differential statement
differential equation what would you
make in terms of integration what could
you say
you'd integrate both sides with respect
to
t now by the way we've been so used to
just saying integrate right and we don't
have to care about what we're
integrating with respect to but can you
see
it is vitally important that you think
about what you're integrating with
respect to because you can integrate
respect to anything okay
any variable i should say so therefore
you get v on this side what do you get
on the right hand side if you integrate
with respect to t
180 t
but i haven't given you a domain so you
have a constant don't you
oops
okay now ordinarily constants are a bit
of pain aren't they okay but you have
enough information to get rid of that
constant don't you or at least to work
out what it is
what is t
it's time it's when i started pouring i
guess
right so therefore you know what the
volume of water is when i started
pouring when t equals zero what volume
of water was there
there was no water in there so the
volume is zero
so when t equals zero
v equals zero
right
therefore zero equals 180 lots of zero
plus c so there's our constant now you
are used to thinking about this in terms
of oh here's a derivative
and it passes through some function in
the function right it passes through
some point i don't know 1 3 or something
like that so you take an x and a y and
you stick them
into your expression right for your your
indefinite integral and then you
evaluate c right
but all of this is just talking about
real things like time and volume okay it
just so happens we call it x and y
because when i think about abstract
situations but these are not abstract
you just need some information
like a pointed space
or like a volume at a time and you can
work out a constant
so
i have this
yes okay
now can you see now this is this is my
bridge this is my connection between
height and time i want to get out of in
terms of i i want to get in terms of
time
what can i do here
i i know what the volume is don't i
this is the volume that's the volume
right so i can say
uh a 12
pi h cubed that's 180 t this is all okay
this is a thing that's changing it's the
volume of water in the cone at any given
time right in the glass that's changing
this is changing too as time goes on
right what did i want i wanted d h on dt
didn't i so i need h in terms of t
let's do it what do i get
h cubed
what's 18 times 12 i have no idea
actually
it's 144 plus 72
what's that is that 216
so 2160
t
over
pi
does that look great did i get rid of
all of the constants on that side i
didn't know okay
now we've been uh we've been very
careful about taking the square roots of
both sides haven't we because it
introduces all kinds of problems with
sine okay but there are no problems here
are there
no problems because i'm not taking the
square root
i'm taking the cube root
i have no problems with that because the
cube root is this is a function right
cubing right and taking the cube root
they are exactly functions and inverse
functions of each other unlike the
square in the square root okay
thanks a lot volume okay there we go
there's h
which is um you know 2 1 6 0 t on pi to
the power of a third so you could
differentiate this couldn't you and off
you go you get your dh on dt and it's
all in terms of t that's really cool
okay now you can go ahead and do that
but
i'm just going to go off this
because i can draw another graph now
what graph could i draw what should my
axes be
what would you choose
vertical axis
i should probably make that the output
shouldn't i h
right so that makes my horizontal axis
time so i'm thinking about how the
height changes as time progresses yes
tell me what does this look like
the two and six zero and the pi
can you see they don't really matter not
really what do they change about this
graph
they change its stiffness or a scale if
you like they're not going to change the
basic shape okay so if i just think
about
this cube root and the t
what's that going to look like
think about your inverse functions if
you thought about x cubed it looks like
this
right
so therefore the cube root of x
if you do your reflection
across y equals x what's it going to
look like
it's going to look like this guy
okay so that's the cube root of x now i
only want part of it don't i because
we've noticed some restrictions on the
domain haven't we okay
when times zero
what is the height
it's zero
so i'm at the origin unlike this guy
he's not defined there okay
but this guy is
what does the rest of it look like we'll
have a look at the rest of the shape
it's going to look something like this
okay yes
does this match what happened the height
of the water was increasing but it was
slowing down as time went on okay
now that looks pretty good shape look
good
there's something wrong with my graph
the same thing that was wrong before
right this graph just like that one it
has a boundary it has the same boundary
that this one has it just so happens
it's on a different axis isn't it okay
so i should end
at some point
when h is 24. now just because of the
observations that we made approximately
you actually also know the end point for
this axis too don't you what is it it's
20 because that's when we said the water
got to the top and i kept pointing but
the
water in the glass didn't change okay